producer star
dakota johnson
hello welcome welcome
chris martin makes a rare appearance in
girlfriend dakota johnson's interview
that's all you can look at during a
virtual q a for the sundance film
festival the coldplay front man
seemingly steps in to help the actress
get her equipment all squared away
hello welcome welcome
peace yup that's chris in the background
as dakota laughs it all off let's watch
that cute cameo one more time
hello welcome welcome
peace
the famously private couple who started
dating in 2017 has been more public with
their romance in recent months case in
point this moment at the coldplay
concert in october
and she's here
[Music]
yup that's the musician sweetly
dedicating his song with bts my universe
to his ladylove
[Music]
at the time chris explained the song's
origin while chatting with zane lowe on
apple music one it's a love song yes
that came from
a loving text the phrase my universe in
this text was that oh that's a cool song
title how do you top this feeling i
don't think it's possible and just last
month dakota gave fans a glimpse into
her relationship with the rockstar the
fifty shades of greystar told luk we've
been together for quite a while and we
go out sometimes but we both work so
much that it's nice to be at home and be
cozy and private i mostly just
like try to stay true to myself dakota
also admits to the mag that she's
guarded and that at 32 she doesn't quite
feel her age
quote i feel both 48 and 26 i've had a
lot of life in my life i had a lot of
life really young so i think i feel
older
in dakota's two latest films cha-cha
real smooth and the lost daughter she
takes on a new role mom although she
doesn't have kids in real life she says
she gets inspired by the mother she
knows my best friend is a mother of two
kids who are my god babies and
um
she's a big part of
if i have to if i play a mother in a
film it's a lot of
um
watching her be a mom
and asking her you know
questions about
what what it really feels like deep on
the inside i mean i'm not a mother
yet so i i don't um have my own
experience to draw from but i did
i have a lot of siblings and i did raise
a lot of them or take care of them in
some in a lot of ways in the lost
daughter dakota plays a woman struggling
with motherhood who finds comfort in
olivia coleman's character lena get up
mommy get up
your mommy's girl you're my big girl
she's driving me great when dakota
caught up with et about the project she
shared why she was so drawn to this role
it was honest it was like the most
honest
script i've read about what it really
feels like to be a woman and
[Music]
i think even for women who don't have
children that it's always
a conversation with yourself of like am
i gonna do that did i [ __ ] up that i
didn't do that did i ruin my life you
know it's like
oh it's such a humongous
part of
our lives